well illegal fentanyl is flooding the
streets across america but don't count
on democrats to do anything about it
they just rejected several amendments in
congress that would strengthen
penalties for people who were
distributing the deadly drug this comes
as cbp announces they seized over 1 000
pounds of fentanyl at the southern
border
last month alone and seizures have risen
78
compared to last year so geraldo 93
000 people in america last year
overdosed on fentanyl
uh it got the crisis got worse as a
result of people not being able to get
legal fentanyl through their doctors
because of all the coveted shutdowns so
they went to the streets and it was
laced with
other drugs which caused overdoses uh
and now democrats don't seem to want to
implement any harsher penalties for
cartels involved in bringing it into the
country well i think that
i remember the crack experience where
crack as opposed to powder cocaine was
treated much more severely
and it's one of the reasons the prisons
filled up i i think that it's a bad
strategy
let me hasten to add that i am in favor
of the border wall being completed
uh but it won't stop the professional
smugglers they'll get that stuff
in i think you have to have an alternate
strategy and what i would do where i in
charge is
i would absolutely legalize marijuana
everywhere in every corner of this
country every kind of marijuana you want
the chewing
the smokies the you know any any way you
want to get stoned
because i believe that if people have
access because people are going to get
stoned one way or the other
if they have access to legal pot i think
that the demand for drugs like fentanyl
which killed prince
it's a killer drug it's so potent you
don't know it wiped out uh you know
uh new england the hit there it struck
so badly
i i think that you've got to understand
that people are going to get high
one way or the other you know jesse
that's one argument that has been made
people have argued that if you legalize
marijuana it will make drug use less
prevalent
um but actually and it would eliminate a
lot of what the cartels do in mexico but
actually
what they've seen is that the cartels
are kind of moving their drugs and
they're building
industrial-sized meth factories now to
replace
their marijuana output as a result of
that legalization
if i couldn't find pot i don't think i'd
go looking for fentanyl
geraldo i'm not sure that that's the
jump but that's another conversation
there's two reasons why the democrats
are against these sentences for fentanyl
one lawyers lawyers do not like
mandatory sentences for
anything because they can't plea bargain
for their clients and the trial lawyer
lobby owns the democrat party they
donated 50 million last cycle to joe
many many millions more to the house and
the senate democrats and this is such a
profitable drug because it's so
small it's almost undetectable and the
profit margins are huge and a lot of
these lawyers represent traffickers and
there's just a lot of money to be made
the mobs control it the cartels control
it so that's why
you're never going to see democrats vote
for tough sentencing laws
and look who did jerry nadler new york
city
eric swalwell san francisco corey bush
st louis
sheila jackson lee houston those just
happen to be the major distribution hubs
for fentanyl and they're against those
tough sentences
have i mentioned how much i dislike
lawyers katie because this is a big
reason why
the first time i like you gerald we'll
make an exception but the other reason
is
the democratic party now doesn't want to
reduce crime they want to reduce
prison populations they believe the fact
that people
are incarcerated a lot of african
americans there
is because we have a white supremacist
system and they are the victims of white
supremacy
so even if they have to you know reduce
sentences if that comes with an uptick
in crime
they don't care so greg you have uh the
opposite take you believe in
legalization
that a num you know implementing more
sentencing for drug crimes
only exacerbates the problem yeah i
think first first of all i
you know the you know in terms of crack
to what
geraldo was talking about the people who
wanted those harsh penalties were black
communities
because that's what was really killing
them but no one actually goes to buy
fentanyl no it's fentanyl isn't a drug
that people go look for
fentanyl is the cheapest ingredient that
you put in other drugs because it has
such a high potency given the fact that
it's tiny
so when people buy like this is what
kills me when when the when the media uh
uh presents um an autopsy they'll say
overdose
and they'll mention the drugs but they
don't mention what exactly
like they'll go oh you had xanax in the
system this has been done with a lot of
ods and you go like nobody over
like nobody accidentally overdoses on
zan actually yeah yeah yeah it's a but
it's it's laced with this stuff
this stuff just makes all the drugs more
powerful
and it's really sloppy so one way to
crack down on these on the street
traffic of fentanyl
is to stop cracking down on the
prescription opiate opioid users because
you're driving those people to the
street
and they're punishing lawful pain in
cancer patients
and a lot of these they're not overdoses
these are people that just stop
breathing because they take the fentanyl
um makes it easier for you you just you
get so relaxed you just stop breathing
that's not an overdose it's a reaction
to fentanyl so we should
view the fentanyl trade as a terrorist
act
that kills thousands of americans
courtesy of china's massive drug trade
uh china knows who makes it uh just like
they knew about the wuhan lab so
if they don't kill the dealer which they
could very easily kill the dealer
we should think about that we should
think about how do we eliminate the
dealers we must know how to do that
and it would be kind of nice but the
bottom line any kind of war on drugs
ain't going to make this better never
has you got to go after the source
and then you got to legalize it and get
people get the police get the
government and the police off people's
backs and dana the source is not just
mexican cartels but their partnership
with the chinese well i think that's the
only point that i wanted to make here
into all of that which is there is an
opportunity that's coming up
what does china really care about one
thing is money power and reputation
the olympics is coming up next february
in china there's already some calls for
from people saying
because of their human rights abuses it
should be boycotted that's maybe a topic
for another day
however there is a meeting coming up on
the end of october it's the g20
this is where um the big economies get
together
and the biden administration has been
trying to do something that the trump
administration was doing as well which
is
to get our allies to all be singing from
the same song sheet
so when you go to that meeting in with
china i think it's in europe somewhere
when they're at the table demanding
something to be done
on this issue of china-laced
fentanyl pills that are coming into the
united states that is a that is a war
type issue and if china you want to get
them to actually do something that would
help
other people force them to close down
that place
we've they've been doing it they're
closing down other things they don't
care about
anybody losing money they just changed
up their whole education
system their whole tech sector they're
bringing everything back in
so i would force them to try to do
something there hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else